Here's a little bit of Python code. Very simple to do exactly this.
Here's our list from the example, and we want to know where 84 will fall.
What position 84 will be in in the sorted list? All we need to do is count.
We start off with this pos variable set to 0. We loop through all the values in the list.
And for each one we say, "Well, is it smaller than the value we're asking about?"
If so, we increment the position and sort of bump it one space to the right in the sorted list.
And then when we're done, we'll just return in that position. So in this list, 84 will be in position 10.
We're going to use this idea now to do something a little more clever.
Let's imagine we've got some list and it has some value V in it.
We know now how we can actually figure out where V will go in the sorted list.
Let's actually put it there. Let's actually put that value in the list at that position.
We'll generate a new list L‘
and we're going to put in that list what's going to be a permutation of these values.
We're going to shuffle around these values, but we're going to put V in its final resting place
as it were the final sorted position and make sure that to its left are all things
less than V and to its right are all things greater than V.
And apart from that, we don't care what the order inside is.
It's kind of a partially sorted list, and we call this partitioning around V.
What I'd like you to do is modify the Python code that we're just looking at
to take the list L and the value of V and return a new list L‘ that has the property
that V is in its final sorted place, everything to the left of it is to the left of it,
and everything to the right of it is to the right of it.